the first Jaws movie directed by Steven
Spielberg is recognized as the first
summer blockbuster to this day Jaws
remains a seventh highest grossing movie
of all time when adjusted for ticket
price inflation the groundbreaking film
about a man-eating shark reshaped the
theater going experience so it makes
sense that the studio would want to
squeeze everything that they could from
the shark-infested property
you're gonna need a bigger boat
three more Jaws films expanded the law
of the ocean's most dangerous animal
with new characters locations and
situations the ground laid by the
franchise has resulted in an influx of
shark themed movies that continue to be
released today whether water beasts
appearing in low budget projects almost
annually understandably the multiple jaw
sequels struggle to achieve the same
Acclaim of Spielberg's project however
even the worst Jaws movies have found an
audience is called Classics meanwhile
the franchise as a whole remains one of
the highest grossing horror franchises
of all time